the more you don't judge the trigger and
you allow it to be there the more it
stops showing up you know what I mean
like it's when you ignore the trigger
that it's going to keep going there
because like you said it's a trigger
it's coming up for a reason so my
biggest thing is always to understand
what are my triggers but what's the
story behind the trigger my ex-husband
left me for another woman you know and
now they're married and they have
children together so that was a trigger
for years with me I think the story that
in everyone's mind in my kind of a
situation whether you're cheating on or
you're left or just someone is cruel to
you is what did I do wrong I want to
talk about cheating somewhere I read
that men cheat to stay and women cheat
to leave why do people cheat them I
think I mean I think people cheat for
different reasons I think I think some
people cheat because they don't honor
that they don't want to be with this
person you know that they maybe the
person isn't right for them
um and they don't want to admit that for
whatever reasons I think some people
cheat because they think the grass is
greener